lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
familiarizarnos con el concepto de
conjunto y también hacer algunas
operaciones con conjuntos para empezar
un conjunto es básicamente una colección
de objetos distintos supongamos que
tenemos un conjunto al cual voy a llamar
x va a ser un conjunto de números aunque
un conjunto puede contener cualquier
cosa
digamos personas puede contener otros
conjuntos puede ser el conjunto de
animales domésticos en fin pero voy a
usar números porque estamos tan
acostumbrados a los números supongamos
entonces que este conjunto x contiene al
número 3 también contiene al número 12
al número 5 el número 13 este que
tenemos aquí es un conjunto
construyamos otro conjunto le voy a
llamar el conjunto y podría llamarle el
conjunto a el conjunto sal no importa el
nombre en este caso le voy a llamar el
conjunto y digamos que en este ejemplo
el conjunto y es la colección de objetos
distintos el número 14 el número 15
el número 6 y el número 3 aquí tenemos
entonces la definición de dos conjuntos
la manera como lo hace usualmente en
matemáticas exponer estas llaves
encerrando los objetos que están
separados por comas hagamos ahora
algunas operaciones básicas entre
conjuntos y la primera operación que
quiero hacer es la intersección vamos a
hacer la intersección de x
con
la intersección de x con ye y x
intersección y va a ser a la vez otro
conjunto esto va a ser igual al conjunto
de los elementos que están tanto en x
como en g entonces para recordarnos bien
lo que significa la intersección de
conjuntos la intersección se relaciona
con la palabra y así la intersección de
x con que es el conjunto elementos que
están en x y están en y entonces a que
va a corresponder en este caso la
intersección veamos a ambos conjuntos
empecemos por el 3 el 3 se encuentra en
x y también se encuentra en ya está en
ambos conjuntos así es que el 3 está en
la intersección de x y que sigamos el
número 12 el número 12 no se encuentra
en y así es que nuestra intersección en
el número 5 tampoco se encuentra en el
número 13 tampoco lo encontramos en y
así es que la intersección tan sólo
consta de un único elemento el número 3
3 es la intersección de x con ye y ya
hemos terminado con la intersección
revisemos ahora otra operación que es
también de las más conocidas
esta es la unión entre dos conjuntos
vamos a hacer la unión del conjunto x
con el conjunto ché y para hacer la
unión hay que considerar el conectivo y
queremos encontrar el conjunto de
elementos que están en x o están en ye
lo podemos imaginar como juntar los dos
conjuntos entonces vamos a ver la unión
de x con ye costa y el concepto clave
aquí es que un conjunto es una colección
de objetos distintos tenemos el número 3
presente en ambos conjuntos aquí no
estamos hablando de objetos distintos de
tres manzanas o tres medallas o cosas
que puede tener la gente no estamos
considerando tan solo el número tres
como objeto de ambos conjuntos por lo
cual 3 está en la unión de x con el
número 12 está en equis o ye el número 5
está en
y soy también el número 3 está en equis
o ye por cierto no nos interesa el orden
de los elementos estos son los elementos
de xy por el lado de los elementos de
jett tenemos el número 14 el número 14
está en la unión de x con el número 15
el número 6 el número 3 que ya
consideramos y aquí tenemos los
elementos de la unión de x con jeff y
una manera de visualizar conjuntos
intersecciones entre conjuntos uniones
entre conjuntos y otras operaciones es
utilizando diagramas de ven supongamos
que este cuadrado
este cuadrado comprende al conjunto de
todos los números aquí tenemos el
conjunto de todos los números y
supongamos que aquí tenemos el conjunto
x
el conjunto x que consta de todos estos
números tenemos el número 3 el número 5
el número 12 y el número 13
este es el conjunto x y también tenemos
el conjunto y lo voy a poner aquí el
conjunto ya que también consta del
número
y lo estoy poniendo en esta región
porque pertenece a x y pertenece a la
intersección el número 14 el número 15 y
el número 6 cuando hablamos de la
intersección de x con jeff estamos
hablando de esta zona donde se traslapan
los conjuntos donde se encuentra el
número 3 que es el único elemento de la
intersección así que esta zona de
traslape corresponde a la intersección
de x con jeff ahora x unión y considera
la combinación de los dos conjuntos
abarca tanto al conjunto x como al
conjunto y los dos conjuntos
eso es x unión y hagamos otro ejemplo
para asegurarnos que entendemos
intersección y unión de conjuntos sea el
conjunto a el conjunto de los números 11
4 12 7 y el conjunto b el conjunto b el
conjunto que contiene a los números 13
12 10 y 3 consideremos primero entonces
lo que va a ser la intersección la
intersección de a déjame ponerlo en q su
color adecuado en el color de a la
intersección de a
con la intersección de esto va a ser
igual a los elementos que están en a y
en b veamos el 11 no está no está más
que nada el número 4 el número 4 está en
a y está en b por lo cual 4 está en la
intersección de a con b el número 12
está en a y está en b por lo cual 12
también está en la intersección de a con
b el número 7 sólo está en el número 13
10 y 3 sólo están en b y ya la tenemos
el conjunto de elementos 4 y 12 es la
intersección de a y b si queremos
podemos etiquetar esto como el conjunto
c en el conjunto c es la intersección de
a con b y es este conjunto que tenemos
aquí hagamos ahora la unión de estos
conjuntos hagamos a deja de poner lo
mejor en naranja
unión
ve cuáles son los elementos que están en
o están en b empecemos por los elementos
que están en a 11 4 12 y 7 son elementos
que están en a incluyamos a los
elementos de ve que no están en a 13 4 y
12 ya los incluimos 10 y 3 puede
escribir esto en el orden que sea no nos
importa el orden al describir un
conjunto así que esto es la unión de a
con b